[Musica]
sì in effetti loro hanno ragione smart è
un termine un po come dire molto
frequentato poi cosa vuol dire
esattamente smart
non c'è dubbio che la traduzione vuol
dire intelligente intelligente con una
sfumatura di furbo ecco se vogliamo è
effettivamente molto frequentato anche
il concetto di smart city allora perché
smart village perché pensiamo che le
declinazioni correnti del concetto di
smart city tendono a essere un po
superficiali i progetti di smart city
sono basati quasi sempre esclusivamente
su tecnologie digitali
ora portare il wifi nelle piazze o per
il corso della città creare una app che
facilita la fruizione dell'offerta
turistica o del sistema di parcheggi di
una città sono certamente cose smart
però non incidono nell hardware della
città non incidono nella gestione
dell'infrastruttura è vero che lo
sviluppo delle tecnologie digitali in
qualche modo a un po spostato il nostro
focus di attenzione perché è vero che
una parte della nostra vita stessa oggi
in qualche modo si svolge in luoghi
digitali in luoghi virtuali parte della
nostra socialità se ne è parlato si
svolge in piazza in salotti digitali
questo però non toglie che la realtà del
nostro vivere si svolge in un luogo
fisico il nostro abitare nostro lavorare
richiedono degli edifici e questi
edifici hanno bisogno di una serie di
servizi tecnologici che a loro volta
fanno uso di quelle che oggi si chiamano
le utilities che per le assumendo sono
energia
acqua e gestione dei rifiuti allora
cos'è smart villaggio è un modello di
smart city che vorrebbe gestire in modo
smart l'infrastruttura della città il
suo hardware e servizi tecnologici che
la fanno funzionare e le utilities che
sono necessarie per questo perché
village
perché un intervento con questo tipo di
ambizione alla scala urbana completa
ahimè non nella nostra realtà socio
politica non ha la possibilità concreta
di essere attuato non siamo in cina dove
si costruiscono da zero città di 3 4 500
mila abitanti ma abbiamo anche un limite
inferiore perché alcuni dei ragionamenti
che facciamo non funzionano applicate al
singolo edificio a un piccolo gruppo di
edifici la taglia d'intervento ideale di
un pezzetto di città che vada da due
trecento abitanti equivalenti a 1.000
2.000 e 3.000 abitanti equivalenti da
qui capite la definizione di smart
village
quali sono le idee alla base di questo
modello quali sono i cosiddetti driver
dell'innovazione 4 punti
fondamentalmente uno il contenimento del
consumo del territorio è un'ovvietà
negli ultimi decenni si è costruito
molto probabilmente troppo i piani
regolatori delle città sono stati basati
su previsioni demografiche che adesso
sono smentite ribasso la conclusione è
che non possiamo pensare in questo tipo
di divisione di consumare ulteriormente
il territorio dobbiamo pensare al riuso
dobbiamo pensare a riqualificare quello
che c'è già quello che non viene
utilizzato quello che viene sotto
utilizzato
un altro discorso riguarda il fatto che
la realtà sociale ci pone in qualche
modo la richiesta di modelli abitativi
innovativi per esempio i giovani fanno
fatica a uscire dal nucleo familiare di
provenienza
arriverò molto tardi a a costituire un
nucleo autonomo con che più o meno
paragonabile a quello tradizionale
in questa fase di passaggio la ricerca
dell'autonomia non è facilitata dal dall
offerta abitativa corrente sarebbe molto
facilitata se ci fosse un'offerta
abitativa un po mirata questo in molti
nuclei familiari che si spaccano alcuni
dei prodotti di questa fissione del
nucleo familiare se mi consentite questo
giochino di parole sarebbero facilitati
se appunto ci fosse anche qui un'offerta
mirata oppure tutti noi
invecchiando vorremmo mantenere più a
lungo possibile la possibilità di vivere
autonomamente ma molto spesso invece di
essere facilitati in questo dalla nostra
abitazione ci troviamo ad essere
ostacolati ragionamenti simili possiamo
farli in ambito lavorativo quindi uno
delle i driver è quello di venire
incontro a queste richieste abbiamo
detto riuso
sappiamo che le strutture edilizie degli
edifici costruiti negli anni 50 60 70
hanno prestazioni
parlo in senso generale molto scadenti
rispetto agli edifici come li pensiamo
oggi quindi questo tipo di progetto deve
prevedere una di filiali ficazione su
tutti questi fronti e poi quello che
dicevamo prima la gestione smart e
integrata dei servizi tecnologici e
degli utili tease che le fanno
funzionare
vediamo concretamente come si possono
applicare queste idee
il primo punto è molto chiaro abbiamo
detto riuso abbiamo detto qual è la
taglia ideale
allora gli esempi sono vengono da soli
insomma per esempio quando abbiamo la
riqualificazione di un'area industriale
piuttosto che di un'area militare
dismessa piuttosto che le altre
situazioni che vedete elencate per
quanto riguarda i modelli abitativi i
termini cohousing korca in residenza
assistita sono termine ormai entrati
abbastanza nello show corrente cos'è
esattamente il cohousing il cohousing è
un modello di aggregazione abitativa in
cui alcune delle funzioni dell'abitare
non vengono tenute all'interno della
singola unità abitativa ma vengono
portati in spazi di uso collettivo
invidioso comune in qualche modo questo
concetto può essere spinto poco può
essere spinto moltissimo abbiamo esempi
in cui ci limitiamo a gestire in comune
solo alcuni servizi
i servizi tecnologici del fabbricato
piuttosto quei servizi di lavanderia
cose di questo genere qui a modelli a
volte anche un po utopici in cui invece
la struttura è pensata proprio in modo
di favorire l'interazione l'integrazione
fra i nuclei familiari che la abitano
il discorso delle residenze assistite e
molto chiaro non è una versione light
della casa di riposo
pensiamo a delle strutture abitative per
persone autonome in cui però l'ergonomia
degli spazi e degli arredi in cui la
dotazione di certi servizi la dotazione
di impianti consente appunto di
mantenere il più a lungo possibile
l'autonomia discorsi simili si possono
fare sul coordinate su altre cose
per quanto riguarda gli aspetti
prestazionali della struttura edilizia e
vabbè andiamo velocemente il primo punto
sicuramente quello dell'efficienza
antisismica se ne parla però in realtà
si fa molto poco si interviene quasi
solo sugli edifici scolastici
ci sarebbe necessità di intervenire su
quasi tutti gli edifici esistenti perché
solo i più recenti in effetti sono
adeguati da questo punto di vista dell
efficienza rispetto alla climatizzazione
che non vuol dire solo isolamento vuol
dire tante cose vuol dire equilibrio tra
l'isolamento le caratteristiche di
inerzia termica del fabbricato che in
questo modo viene avere un buon
comportamento invernale ed estivo vuol
dire una gestione smart degli apporti
solari che vengono utilizzati quando
sono positivi e vengono bloccati o
filtrati quando invece generano solo un
carico termico vuol dire per esempio
sfruttare il ruolo del verde intorno o
sopra ho addosso al fabbricato che può
essere importante e poi anche aspetti
ancora le prestazioni acustiche le
prestazioni antincendio voglio dire solo
una cosa su questo è importante stare
attenti che questi diversi elementi
vengono gestiti in modo coordinato
perché a volte succede che si interviene
su una cosa a discapito di altre
facciamo un esempio tragico che abbiamo
visto un anno fa in cui intervento di
efficientamento energetico la
realizzazione di un isolamento a
cappotto di una torre a nord kensington
a londra ha portato delle conseguenze
disastrose
si parla di 71 morti conosciamo tutti la
storia per un incendio banale nato da un
corto circuito di un frigorifero al
quarto piano
ma l'isolamento a cappotto materiale
altamente infiammabile ha diffuso
rapidissimamente l'incendio a tutti i
piani superiori dell'edificio con le
conseguenze che sappiamo quindi vanno
gestite in modo coordinato le cose
veniamo al tema della gestione dei
servizi e delle utility è un tema un po
complicato cerco solo di darvi delle
idee
oggi quando parliamo di gestione delle
reti energetiche
penso in particolare alla gestione della
rete elettrica la cosa più complessa e
garantire il bilanciamento della rete
bilanciamento fra le emissioni e i
prelievi è sempre stato un esercizio
complesso questo ma oggi lo è
particolarmente perché una parte
rilevante delle fonti energetiche non è
programmabile
adesso una quota rilevante delle energie
messe in rete viene dal fotovoltaico
all'eolico
il che ovviamente positivo sono fonti
rinnovabili che non consumano
combustibili fossili però non sono fonti
che possiamo accendere e spegnere a
seconda del fabbisogno
questo comporta dei costi di gestione
della rete molto elevati
immagino che qualcuno di voi nella vita
si sia preso a qualche volta la briga di
guardare come è fatta la bolletta
elettrica
se la guardate troverete che l'incidenza
di costo dell'energia è una quota
minoritaria
adesso è al di sotto del 30 per cento ci
parla del 27 per cento
per il resto sono imposte e il grosso
dei costi sono i cosiddetti oneri di
rete sono legati anche questo discorso
qui allora cosa è la qual è la cosa
smart da fare è cercare appunto di
evitare questi oneri di rete come si fa
questa cosa qui si potrebbe fare questa
cosa qui creando quello che si chiama un
sistema efficiente di utenza aggregando
una serie di utenze differenti tra di
loro una serie di utenze fatte di utenze
di solo consumo utenze di sola
produzione utenze miste di questo e
quello i cosiddetti prosumers
bilanciandole anche attraverso
l'utilizzo di strumenti specifici e
anche facendo uso in parte di
sistemi di accumulo che consentono come
dire a questo a questo sistema
efficiente di utenza di equilibrarsi
quanto più possibile in se stesso cioè
di interfacciarsi con la rete pubblica
in un unico punto è di limitare gli
scambi con la rete al minimo
indispensabile per fare questo
ragionamento qui ovviamente dobbiamo
mettere all'interno di questo sistema
dei sistemi di autoproduzione alcuni
sistemi di autoproduzione sono solo
elettrici appunto quelli più frequentati
sono fotovoltaico l'eolico eccetera
altri sistemi besse danno una produzione
combinata di energia elettrica e di
energia termica ed è la cosiddetta
cogenerazione cogenerazione ad alta
efficienza si definisce solitamente si
può produrre anche energia frigorifera
ancora in questo caso si parla di iii
generazione sono sistemi molto
efficienti che però richiedono di
sfruttare contemporaneamente il termico
e l'elettrico nell'ambito della singola
utenza questo è difficile si riesce a
fare qualche volta ma non molto
frequentemente nell'ambito di un sistema
di un aggregato ampio invece questo è
possibile molto di più complessivamente
riusciamo appunto a a creare un sistema
equilibrato in sé è sostanzialmente
indipendente dalla rete
in questo discorso qui in qualche modo
entrano anche la gestione dell'acqua e
dei rifiuti
i modelli molto avanzati si può pensare
addirittura di utilizzare i
sottoprodotti del ciclo dell'acqua del
ciclo dei rifiuti integrandoli nel ciclo
della produzione energetica però andiamo
in un discorso un po complesso parlando
di gestione smart dell'acqua dico una
cosa sola la più banale
nei nostri nelle nostre abitazioni noi
consumiamo da 150 250 litri di acqua al
giorno per abitante la gran quantità di
quest'acqua oltre metà viene utilizzata
per le cassette di risciacquo dei
servizi igienici ora è una banalità ma è
ovvio che è un assurdo
altro che smart sprecare una quantità
così rilevante di acqua potabile per
quel servizio li guardo da fare è invece
intercettare le acque meteoriche
accumularle e creare una rete duale
interno dei fabbricati che di acqua non
potabile per questo servizio qui per
l'irrigazione per gli usi antincendio
per tutti quegli usi che non richiedono
appunto l'acqua potabile questo così per
darvi qualche idea
chiudo dicendo due cose quali sono i
benefit di questo tipo di modello e
quali sono gli ostacoli le barriere per
la sua realizzazione
i benefit li potete immaginare da se c'è
una risposta a certe domande di tipo
sociale
se è un risparmio energetico c'è una
riduzione dell'impatto
come dire dell'impronta ambientale del
nostro abitato rispetto perché andiamo a
ridurre gli inquinanti consumo di
combustibili fossili l'emissione in
atmosfera di emissioni di gas serra ma
anche l'inquinamento verso i corpi di sì
e la produzione di rifiuti solidi ma ci
sono delle bandiere ci sono delle
barriere in parte sono di tipo culturale
perché
una visione così ho un po complessa
mediamente chi investe nel settore
immobiliare non ha un tipo di visione
così articolata e andrebbe un po
incentivato
purtroppo ci sono anche delle barriere
di tipo normativo i regolamenti rispetto
alla gestione in particolare delle
utilities anziché favorire questo tipo
di aggregazione lo ostacolano quindi sta
un po a noi se ci convince questo tipo
di ragionamento premere sui decisori su
qui ad otto i regolamenti per rendere
più facilmente praticabile questo tipo
di di realtà ecco di salute
[Applauso]